I couldn't just leave it at the open
question what if it sucks so I am fisted
in a video not too long ago basically
theorizing what if this thing is as bad
as the initial critical reviews are
pegging it for um you know what does
that mean how could that have happened
and what will happen after that well
having done that and posed that question
it would be a little reticent of me to
not actually watch the thing and answer
the question does it suck short answer
no it's not great though not so far
anyways I'm three episodes in I'm
calling it a night on that those first
three episodes well that first episode
that first episode is not good guys the
first episode is not good second
episodes better second episode is not
great but it's solidly good third one
kind of in the middle it was a slight
step down but it wasn't as bad as the
first one there's a lot that I didn't
like about the first episode it just the
whole thing just started really wonky
because you know right off the bat for
pretty much that is harab so like I
don't I'm not rooting for anybody here I
know we're supposed to be rooting for
Danny but I couldn't I couldn't get a
feel for him because he just shows up I
don't know where with no context we have
no idea who he is I mean I know I know
who he is I know who he's supposed to be
the hero and whatnot but this is his
chance to give his first impression of
who he is as a character and he just
comes across as really naive and a
little weird and maybe as we get more
backstory his being and acting the way
he did when he first showed up will make
more sense once we have that context I
don't know
and that first episode just had a lot of
really lazy writing like I'll give you a
couple of examples there were there were
examples all over the episode but a
couple of key ones that really kind of
hammered it home for me
the first was with Borg he got pretty
much right
but that this guy was gonna be an
obstruction he's more or less running
the company and you know right awful
he's not gonna just want to hand that
over that would have been enough I mean
regardless of whatever history he or
Danny and Danny did or didn't have
nobody's just gonna want to go oh you're
the guy who vanished 15 years ago here's
the company I've been running for a
while no one's gonna do that the
inherent conflict and you know the
reasons why he would doubt that it's all
right just baked into the scenario it
all sells itself but then they had to
overreach and we get this flashback
where he's this ridiculous caricature of
a dick to a young Danny it's like it's
like the Cobra Kai and Karate Kid I mean
it's that level of over-the-top really
cheesy then and it's just unnecessary
another example of really lazy writing
Big Al the the homeless guy in the park
because okay first of all Danny's in the
park and that and that's fine in and of
itself homeless guy comes up to him and
is you know friendly makes shad okay yep
that's fine too then homeless guy pulls
our iPhone then he just got a hold of
and offers to look up information on
anyone for this guy what a crazy
coincidence
it's lazy contrived writing and yet I
understand they did a little bit more
with him than that but it's just when he
first showed up and it was just this
ham-fisted hey I'll look up anything you
want on this iPhone for you really
really so that first episode I it was it
was not now look if I'm being fair the
performances were fine none of them were
great but they were all doing but I'd
say about the best they could with the
material it was the writing that really
sucked in that first episode now we got
into the second episode and the whole
mental institution setting was a much
but that was I was far more engaged by
Danny's plight in that because it's a
great scenario that makes total sense
like he knows who he is but he he can't
prove it and he can't realistically
expect people to believe him when he
says that
so that scenario and watching the doctor
look into it see his interaction
those few other pages that was
interesting that was a dynamic I really
like I'm not gonna go so far as to say I
wish he had spent more time in the
mental institution because it easily
could have gotten over played really
well maybe they could have squeezed
another half upside out of it but for
that second episode I I thought it
worked really well in up to the stakes
for Danny's situation cuz that's the
other thing as of right now I three
episodes in I still don't know why
Danny's back I understand more or less
where he was for 15 years I don't
understand why he's come back so in
terms of the hindrances and you know
these people from his past being mean to
him and and you know not wanting to give
him back the company is like it's hard
for me to get invested in that because
he said himself he doesn't really want
the company and seems to be at this
point it's more just spite but I don't
actually know what Danny wants I don't
know why he's there I don't know what
his goal is I and I get you know he's
got the destiny stopped the hand and all
that but I don't know how invested he is
in that as a character is the embrace
his destiny is he's seeking out is he
rebelling against it I have no idea
three episodes in but again that second
episode I think just gave me an
immediate for this episode on the
situation that it just made the stakes
more palpable for me he's in a place
where he doesn't belong cuz he's not
really crazy he needs to get out great
that's much more relatable than to all
this stuff that I just because I didn't
know where he was coming from or what he
was trying for now in that second
episode was more immediate he wants to
get out of here awesome I can totally
get that third episode was a little bit
more meandering still better than the
first one though Colleen winged I can't
really decide what I think of her right
now a [ __ ] again she's being played
fine but the characters just the
character I I'm not sure I'm prepared to
say she's cliche but she's very
predictable I'll say that about her
there's something that surprising me and
that's sort of the corporate intrigue
and I'm surprised by that on two levels
one that there's as much of it as there
is then something that ostensibly was
kind of sold as watch this guy use kung
fu to kick people's butts and to I'm
actually kind of really intrigued by the
corporate intrigue it's actually the
thing that's
drawing me in the most right now mostly
having to do with Harold Meacham I find
him really interesting now I'm actually
not sure if he's a good character or if
they're just peeling back the layers in
revealing tiny bits of information about
him at a really good sort of pace
because he first shows up it's like wait
you're supposed to be dead so
immediately I have a bunch of questions
but they're not questions like I don't
get what's going on they're more
questions like how does this work is
because I'm I'm immediately wondering
okay who knows that he's dead why did he
fake to be dead why is it okay for his
son to know how active is he and running
everything's does he ever leave that
place you know all these questions just
sort of bubbled up and I'm like I'm
interested to see the answers to these
now I mean it could go wrong and
intriguing mystery always can but as of
right now I am intrigued by his
character again I'm not sure that means
he's actually a good character I'll have
a better sense of that once we get more
answers about what his deal is and I can
see and get a sense of whether or not I
still enjoy him when I know his deal or
if my enjoyment of him is completely
tied to the mystery aspects of his
character I honestly don't know could go
either way I'm like David Wenham as an
actor but his American accent not very
I'm actually surprised with word and joy
that they I mean after painting Ward
completely one-dimensional II
over-the-top in that first episode there
they're bringing out a surprising amount
of depth and nuance and shades of grey
to both of them Julie especially I think
because it seemed really obvious early
on like okay she's the one who's got a
simple sympathize with Danny and words
gonna be the jerk but they kind of go
back and forth and you get the sense
that Ward doesn't actually really want
to be running this company but you know
he's sort of a dick by nature where his
joy seems to be a nicer person by nature
but she wants to be running this company
and to sort of see that and see what
they are striving for versus maybe what
they want on a more emotional level sort
of you get a sense of that struggle and
I'd like that I find it in very very
engaging I find a very human so I'm I've
been surprised by the
that they've laid in and it couldn't
just come across as contradictory for me
it hasn't I found it I found that
intriguing and the other thing that I
think is worth mentioning the fight
scenes are are not great there are some
moments in them but I remember that oh
that very first fight scene in the lobby
when Danny's fighting the guards that
one of them you know comes at him with
the baton you know it does a swing he
did it so slow and it wasn't like slow
motions like he just did a slow swing so
it was really obvious that there was
plenty of time for the actor to get in
there and do the movie was supposed to
do and I think that's the two things
going wrong with these fight scenes one
there are more cut heavy than really a
martial arts kung fu II kind of think
should because the real joy of kung fu
movies and kung fu fights are long takes
but they really aren't they just they
just feel a little bit too slow like
they need it they needed to ramp up the
footage at like just 15% faster and it
would have felt better because at the
speed these people in movie at it also
makes the hits feel like they don't hurt
and not all the time but enough of the
time that it really took me out of the
fights and the fights over what I was
kind of looking forward to the most so
that's that's not great again though as
much as I I have been complaining more
than I've been praising I guess it's not
bad and I think it is getting over hated
by critics and I want to kind of address
that just real quickly with a couple of
things if if I were to hazard a guess
having not actually read reviews but
only sort of read what the consensus is
right now but with the critics if I were
to guess maybe what the problem is is
that this show is just at least as far
as I've gotten into it it's just kind of
unremarkable it's not bad but Marvel is
just capable of so much more and it's
just kind of there
it's very by the numbers it's very wrote
it doesn't seem to have a particularly
strong identity I mean one thing that
you can say whether you love them or not
is that all three of the previous
Netflix shows daredevil Jessica Jones
Luke Cage certainly all had read
clear really strong identities I don't
get that so much from this show
it just doesn't stand out it's actually
to the point um what I was talking about
the characters I had I will have cut it
by my hat I had to get my phone out
bring up IMDB I am debita to get
character names I I had actually
considered you know doing this review in
the morning as opposed to late at night
after watching these three episodes and
I realized I couldn't cuz I will
probably forgotten a lot of the stuff I
wanted to talk about and so that's the
thing it doesn't it doesn't leave a huge
lasting impact I think that's it's it's
sort of detriment again as far as I've
gotten
now the things that are good are good
enough that I'm not bailing I'm gonna
keep watching and I'm gonna I'm gonna
see if it can keep improving and
building on the the bits that work oh
and I want to call one other thing I
have a really bad feeling that because
the show is not as bad as the sort of
the initial critical response would have
led us to believe I have a fear and a
feeling that a lot of fans are going to
over defend this and over praise it like
because in their heads they need to
offset the critics because the critics
win that's no good so fans are gonna end
up going no they're wrong it is good
it's great when in reality it's just
okay so and critics who are saying it's
Bennigan's I I haven't read a ton of the
reviews but if critics were saying this
is a bad show they're wrong it's a it's
a fine show it's not an especially good
one though again not as far as I've
gotten into it so picking up some of the
stuff I you said in my video you know
what if this sucks what will that mean
for fan reaction I feel like I'm already
seeing to a certain extent that fans are
overshooting their praise trying to
compensate for the critical land bassing
it got and I I wonder if we're gonna end
up with Marvel's first you know BBS
scenario where the majority of people
didn't love it you know we're either did
they didn't care for it or they were
neutral on it but the people who did
like it are going to defend it as if
it's something better than it actually
is I don't know we'll see and like I
said I do plan to stick with the show I
don't know if I'll if I'll follow up
with
more reviews it's just gonna depend on
whether or not my overall assessment at
this point of it being basically fine
but kind of forgettable changes at all
if it changes significantly if this
thing goes completely to hell or if it
becomes great I'll probably come back
and do another video if not I might
leave it at this we'll see but how far
have you gotten into iron fist so far
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council you geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]